this is my baby my two babies i have two
babies
i'm like i love you guys
i do not do tough love
it's your life
hey guys it's sona and this is sona
fixes your life so
let's raise your kids at sarah j
annaleda says is sleep a thing if not
how do you deal coffee speed i kid but
not a mom yet so please fill me in
sleep is a thing i don't know they were
like people were talking about how you
don't sleep and you don't sleep as much
as you did before i can operate on very
little sleep
but like i want to say that was the
first like few months and then they
start getting into this rhythm where
they sleep for longer stretches of time
and before you know it
if you're lucky you're doing okay
so
yeah sleep is the thing people scared us
people were like you're never gonna
sleep again
and i'm like
i am i'm sometimes sleeping but also i'm
lucky because my parents come and help a
lot and i would nap during the day
so
god
sleep is a thing sleep is it is
it is a thing you do sleep at some point
you can't not sleep what are we gonna do
not sleep that's crazy no you sleep you
just don't sleep as much
and you can't sleep in the way you used
to
and you can't sleep it's the worst is
when you start getting into like a deep
sleep and then they start crying
that sucks but uh now my babies are are
sleeping a lot better so i'm sleeping a
lot better
it's a thing you're welcome
you know what
you're welcome at jd mickelson says what
is the best product you bought as a new
mom
there are things oh my god my bouncer
that's that's awesome there's also this
like activity center you just plop them
in there and then they like play with
things and that keeps them occupied for
a long time
uh my mom had this
thing that you put them in and they push
it with their legs and they could go
around that keeps them up i mean it's
all what keeps them occupied
uh
and oh my god the formula maker
so i you know i do
i breastfeed and i also use a lot of
formula
and i for the longest time in the middle
of the night like powder
water you shake it and then you feed it
now there's this formula maker i have
where i just put the bottle underneath
and press the button and it does it for
me
and i'm like
was i living in the prehistoric ages
before what did i do why did i do that
to myself it's one of those things you
wish you had earlier um
also the uh sleep suit that we have the
baby merlin sleep suit that makes them
look like they can't move and they're
like
they're like this they look like sumo
wrestlers that is clutch
oh my god i'll buy 80 of those you're
welcome at juggieto says do you believe
in tough love
ugh
i wish i could say yes
i mean tough love
yeah no i mean i believe in it i believe
that works for some people i don't know
i can't do it though i'm just like very
like i love you
that's me like every day i'm just like
oh this is my baby my two babies i have
two babies
i'm like i love you guys
i do not do tough love
i can't do it i can't figure it out
but if you believe in it that's cool
you're welcome at vgwill50
are you irritated when conan sends you
pics of sushi without you you look
awesome thank you
yes i am very irritated although now i'm
kind of back to doing the podcast so i
make him take me to sushi every time we
record so that's my way of
getting back to him and also when i go
to sushi even without him i put it on
the corporate card
all right cool you're welcome
and thank you so much for the compliment
that's really nice
[Music]